das ist mein Huhn Wilma und Wilma hat
ein ziemlich großes Problem
[Musik]
als ich heute zu meinen Hühnern kam habe
ich gleich gesehen dass irgendwas mit
ihr nicht stimmt sie hat sich
abgesondert und ihr Rücken ist total
nach hinten abgefallen in so einer
Pinguin Haltung und das heißt legend
nach draußen kommen und daran sterben ja
deswegen ist es so unglaublich wichtig
dass wir den Weg frei machen irgendwie
rauskriegen zumindest helfen das zu
leben was jetzt am meisten hilft ist
einfach so ein kleines Bar day mit einem
warmen Bade zur Muskelentspannung und
einer schönen Bauchmassage
hast du gut gemacht ich halte euch
natürlich über Wilma auf dem Laufenden